how's it going everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and please excuse how my
voice sounds today i was at a concert
saturday night and sunday night so my
voice is gone side note if you like
k-pop be sure to follow my k-pop channel
and even though my voice is gone we
still have to talk about this epic news
that is also kind of sad at the same
time as it turns out there were actually
supposed to be other members of the
illuminati members that i know fans
would have loved to see and some of them
were actually rumored to be in the movie
but unfortunately did not make their
debut however we are finding out a lot
about the movie now that it's finally
been released and the producers and the
writers and the director are doing
interviews now so we're finding out a
lot more about the movie and what could
have been and as it turns out they
actually did film some of these scenes
with these other members of the
illuminati but cut them which is really
sad because we could have seen some
members like ghostwriter and magneto
it's actually been revealed that there
were five other members of the
illuminati that were cut from the movie
so let's go ahead and break down this
latest report in this video and of
course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest marvel videos i should
also add that there are definitely going
to be spoilers for multiverse of madness
in this video so if you haven't seen it
yet now's your time to click away
although i'm pretty sure the entire
roster of the illuminati is out there
now but let's talk about who could have
possibly joined them and we're gonna
start off with a personal favorite of
mine deadpool now i was actually pretty
upset that deadpool did not appear in
this movie in any way shape or form i
just personally feel that it would have
been a great way to bring deadpool into
the mcu however there was never any
guarantee that it would be the exact
same deadpool from the fox universe but
it would have been a great way to do it
and before the movie came out there were
actually rumors going around that
deadpool was going to appear in one of
the post credit scenes for multiverse of
madness but instead we just got bruce
campbell kind of looking at the camera
and laughing jokes on us i guess however
as it turns out there was some truth to
that rumor as that was actually supposed
to happen the original plans were for
deadpool to appear in one of the
post-credit scenes this report is coming
from james clement from the weekly
planet podcast and according to him and
his sources he was informed of five
different characters that had scenes
that were filmed but ultimately cut from
the final version of the film in fact
the last thing that he was quoted saying
is that and deadpool was going to be in
the post credits scene and this is a
true bummer because i think a lot of
fans would have really loved to see this
but recently the writer of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
michael waldron came out and said that
it just didn't really work now this
could be to several different reasons
since there were five characters cut
there were probably different reasons
for each of these scenes being cut but
for deadpool we know that ryan reynolds
has been actively working on deadpool 3.
so perhaps it just didn't work with the
storyline and you never know it could
have just been another joke post-credit
scene and wouldn't have actually meant
that he would be in the mcu but you
never know i'm actually thinking that
ryan reynolds has probably written a
pretty good way for deadpool to make his
way from the fox universe to the mcu and
i'm really crossing my fingers that it's
deadpool kills the fox universe and
kills all of the characters in it and
then goes to the mcu so i'm not
completely bummed but it's still a
pretty big bummer we didn't see deadpool
now another character that was supposed
to be in the film that had a cut scene
was actually r mordo earth 616 is mordo
the one who we all assumed would be the
bad guy of doctor strange too because in
the first film they set him up to be the
villain and he started taking out
sorcerers and according to this report
he was going to go up against wanda and
wanda was going to kill him they could
have possibly not put that in the movie
so they could have him come back in
another doctor strange movie after all
he is a pretty prominent character in
the comics so it's kind of good that
they left that open because now we can
return then this report mentions balder
the brave now this would have actually
been pretty cool especially if you
consider the recent report that daniel
craig was supposed to play somebody a
part of the illuminati and that
character was reportedly according to my
buddy paul over at heavy spoilers balder
the brave now there are mixed reports
about this both reports say that daniel
craig james bond himself was supposed to
be a part of the illuminati however paul
says he was supposed to be bald of the
brave but justin kroll from deadlines
states that he was actually supposed to
be playing mr fantastic now while i
think it would have been really cool to
see daniel craig as mr fantastic i
actually think he would much better fit
the role of balder the brave now balder
the brave in the comics is an asgardian
and he's the half brother and friend of
thor and that's why i think it would
have been really really cool to see him
just because of that connection now i
heard some things before the movie came
out about this scene with baldr the
brave and apparently he was supposed to
die pretty much right away apparently
what was supposed to happen was that the
scarlet witch would collapse the roof
down and it would fall on top of him and
kill him in his chair i'm not sure if
that was what they actually filmed but
that's a rumor that i heard a while ago
and then there was supposed to be a
magneto scene yes magneto was supposed
to be a part of the illuminati and it
was actually supposed to be michael
fassbender's magneto and this is really
really interesting because professor x
was obviously played by patrick stewart
it wasn't james mcavoy's professor x so
it's weird that they wouldn't get ian
mckellen to do it or perhaps maybe they
did and he turned the roll down or just
didn't work out but there is a line in
the movie that is actually very
interesting professor x says just
because someone stumbles and loses their
way doesn't mean they're lost forever
now this is very interesting because
this is almost an exact quote from days
of future past where patrick stewart's
professor xavier is communicating via
telepathy to his past self james
mcavoy's professor x where he says just
because someone stumbles and loses their
path doesn't mean they're lost forever
sometimes we all need a little help and
what's interesting is that he was
speaking about magneto then so perhaps
there could have been some connection
between professor x's magneto and
michael fassbender's magneto now the
main reason i would have actually loved
to see this is because there's a
storyline in the comics where magneto is
wanda's father it's complicated because
it was retconned and then it was
retconned out again but for a moment in
time that's how it was magneto was the
father of the scarlet witch and
quicksilver and i'm really wondering
that if they decided to include magneto
in the actual final cut of the film if
they would have talked about that if he
simply would have addressed her as his
daughter that would have been a definite
bigger truth bigger than the one that
professor x dropped on doctor strange
and what's really interesting is that
ian mckellen even tweeted recently that
if he had a daughter he would want her
to be like elizabeth could this be
hinting at a possible future story where
magneto is the father of the scarlet
witch in the actual mcu i'm not sure but
i really really hope so and of course
last but definitely not least
ghostwriter was supposed to be a part of
the illuminati now nothing has been said
about who the actor was supposed to be
to play ghost rider but since this
report says that the scenes were shot
that means that there was indeed an
actor playing ghost rider it's not like
this was an idea but they never shot it
they actually shot this now i'm kind of
okay with them not including all of
these cameos because they're all gonna
die that's what james clement states in
his podcast that these characters were
all going to die they were going to join
the other members of the illuminati and
fight and lose to wanda and yeah i would
have loved to see that but i'd like a
permanent ghost rider in the mcu i'd
like a permanent magneto and other x-men
and deadpool and if they found a really
perfect actor to play one of these roles
i'd like to be surprised down the road
now don't get me wrong i really really
really want john krasinski to play mr
fantastic in the main mcu i think he
looked absolutely perfect as mr
fantastic and i think of course his
acting was on point this is something
that i think needs to happen after all
in multiverse of madness they
established that some variants can look
exactly the same all of the doctor
strange variants look the same and the
wanda variant looked the same as well so
fingers crossed that our earth 616 mr
fantastic looks just like john krasinski
so he can play that role and of course i
would absolutely love for his wife to
play sue storm as well but in the
meantime let me know what you think
about these cut scenes would you have
liked to have seen these which i'm
assuming the answer is yes but let me
know how you feel about this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof